cheers aaron's back
wait now that rich is on let's talk
about who's not showing up today rich
did you hear about zach
makes wilson want to drink
[Laughter]
we're out of booze here honey tj's uh tj
and chris are doing a good job
yeah i was seeing you're pouring mimosas
there today well you know want me to
come back
we had a uh we had an extra bottle care
of wheels up so i
i took it out i took it out of the uh
took it out of the wine cellar and
brought it in for the boys today
all right so richard tell us about tokyo
gold what has been your favorite
highlight of the day
what should we stop and watch before we
get to tomorrow the day
the favorite highlight of the day was
the the group
of uh peers of uh
lydia jacoby in seward alaska
watching them watch her
win her event and win gold you know
um when she's from you know a state that
has
one uh long course pool
in the entire state in anchorage alaska
which was a two-hour
drive from her from her hometown so she
and her mom
rented an airbnb so she could train
there for months
and she winds up winning gold and
she's 17 and then just seeing all of her
classmates and friends in that town just
hopping
up and down or slapping the floor and
all i could think of it's like they were
kind of like for the lack of better
phrase
like the hamsters in in her wheel you
know like
they were like connected to her and
giving her power
and strength without her even knowing
and it's what we love about the olympics
is a story
like that and seeing how it affects the
small town and
and the first ever swimmer from the
state of alaska
to make a swimming team and she wins
gold and it's a 17 year old she's a
little
she's a kid and just seeing all of that
it's just
it just gets you in all the fields it
really does one of only yeah one of only
10
olympians from the state of alaska all
time which is kind of incredible
what's it like there i know what's it
like they're rich with the simone biles
news i'm curious about what it feels
like there and what are you hearing yeah
i mean like here we are middle of the
day
you know or middle of our prep and then
all of a sudden word filters oh by the
way simone biles is
is withdrawn and you know we went
through the entire show
thinking it was a physical medical issue
um and um obviously we get off the air
and we find out it's something
completely different
and i saw your guys conversation about
it because um you guys posted it on
twitter
and i thought you you you kind of you
know you you you if you will stuck the
landing i mean
um look there's two ways to look at it
you know
that i've already seen some of the
responses to your your guys conversation
and
and there's going to be a lot of people
saying you know she signed up for the
olympics
this is what you got this is what comes
with the territory
and and suck it up
but we live in a world now where
uh mental health and mental awareness
is just it or should be viewed just as
seriously as anything that requires a
crutch
or a cast to heal and um
and so you know the
we don't know the pressures of being an
olympic athlete
and not even many olympic athletes would
know
maybe the pressures of what simone biles
uh must deal with because simone
does uh maneuvers with her body that no
other human being
can do or has attempted
so she knows what it requires to to
prepare
mentally physically to pull off what she
needs to pull off
and it's you know uh the new york times
story that you
were quoting sues i mean what is more
jarring than to see somebody say that
the thing they're looking forward to
most is the olympics being
over and when somebody signs up for
something they might sign up for it
because
they feel it's what's expected of her or
that she would be letting others down
sponsors parents family members friends
teammates and then once you accept the
assignment
you know a human being comes to maybe
regret it
and i just look at it and think to
myself how sad
it must feel and how sad it must be
for and to her that she views the
olympics
as something she regrets agreeing to do
and what it must take
in order to in the moment look her
teammates in the face and say
this is just not going to happen today
and i feel so sad for her
and i do hope uh although as you pointed
out susan you're
in your in your soliloquy take however
you want to put it
i i mean what what can happen between
now and her next events
for something like this to be no longer
a consideration i i don't know
i don't know whether it's coaching i
don't know whether it's
time i'm not sure what it is but you
said
it perfectly that mental health is the
same as having any other injury i think
was
brandon marshall i think who i covered
in college football that you know
through the national football league who
really brought that to light as of late
and
you cannot discount that and i have zero
interest in the trolls who are going to
say anything about it's her job
it's her job but she's a human being and
she's 24. the weight of the world is on
her shoulders
literally literally physically no
literally
kind of anyway the point is
she's there we hope she comes back and
it sounds like from her latest sound
bite that she's going to come back which
is great
well i hope so because it's what you
know would
um hopefully make but but but that's
that's just us you know that's me that's
us that's that's fans
that's that's what we're we're we're
hoping for
i just hope that it's something that
makes her happy
you know and and you know and if she's
not going to if she's fearful of of
hurting herself because she's not you
know or she's
thinking about it midair mid twist
for the 15th time i mean my god she
could really hurt herself
yeah this is not this is not running
this is not this is not skeet
this is i mean what she does is super
human
i mean the only thing that we could all
relate to and i know
you know brockman definitely can is just
you know your golf swing which
is not anything remotely close to this
but all i'm saying is that sometimes
you're sitting there and you're thinking
you think too much about it but all that
just requires is a lost golf ball
or for us a mulligan you know for her
it's like she could wind up in the
hospital
you know or or she's fearful
of not performing up to her standard
and and that's just to me a very sad
thing
uh but i'm also and we are also
we we we have you know our default
is empathy and sympathy and you know
there's a a lack of that
everywhere in the world today so
uh i do hope to see her again but only
if it makes her happy
before we talk football what has been
your favorite highlight today because i
know you get giddy with some of these
crazy highlights
shoes uh today's rich richest
shuttlecock minute
careful which we have created we created
well we created it to
put a spotlight on lesser known sports
like that but it really
is uh a construct that allows me to say
the word shuttlecock with abandon
on television um today's sport was
dressage
that's what i just said was my sport i
said if i i said that is the one sport
that i could compete in i could do that
just saying
dressage uh a little payoff
massage um we got to the half pass
which is the horse sort of going
sideways yep
um and i said that that reminded me of
leaving dominic's in ann arbor
uh frequently when i was in college that
led to a full pass
on occasion that was my comment on
dressage wow
today in my if you will shuttlecock
minute yeah can you be careful with that
i don't want you to pull a steve levy
okay just be careful
you're making me nervous with that over
and over again person serving mimosas to
the staff during the program suze i mean
the rest of the crew what are you doing
i i just like everyone to be happy
you know that's what i'm all about brock
brockport are you having mimosas too
no i don't know i haven't had any uh
he's probably
the most rich just for the record he's
got two empty glasses and
two thumbs pointing straight at him
speaking of which we did this
we should have you do sneaky good games
to see if it actually improves your
ability
wow wait so during the football season
fridays we we slam some mimosas and then
pick games
i guess i mean you tell me if it
improves because i
i think i didn't i text you a couple of
weeks ago or during my
during my durian during my
covid recuperation i think i found an
old uh
video of you with your toeing the line
yeah that was terrible
your gambling segment where you were
like forty percent or something yeah i
think we went over i don't think
anything
else you know well i mean can't hurt
maybe we get an alcohol sponsor rich i
mean let's
make things happen i mean i think that
the rich eisen show brought to you by
viv cleat co sounds
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
talking about i'm just saying
that's because if it's free it's you i
think all right by the way right don't
joke
me too rich you know the way i am
thoughts on aaron rodgers appearance as
he came into green bay today
rich well there's two things about it
first thing
um it's the personal and the
professional which one do you want first
personal or professional personal which
one do you want personal
i would like to personally thank him for
uh taking us from draft day all the way
to this day on the rich eisen show for
all of the content that we were able to
discuss
uh for it my god that really was um
quite frankly uh that got us that got us
through the storm
um but uh
it looks like whatever concessions that
got made
it's as close to the tom brady
um exit strategy that one can get
um without what getting what tom
got which is complete free agency um i
don't know what peter said in hour one
but it sure looks like
this is the end of rogers stay unless
something
remarkable happens another wrench to use
his phrase gets thrown in and they win a
super bowl
i don't know how you let aaron rodgers
walk then
um and then you know
otherwise if it just winds up let's just
say in the same way this season went
2022 was the year that the packers kind
of pegged anyway
to put uh jordan love in there and
that's why rogers knew that and brought
everything to a head
right now um to get what he wanted
contractually
so he can get out and get to a spot
if that's what he wants um
it would require green bay to trade him
but they would want to get something for
him rather than
you know let him play it out and then
walk
for nothing because that's when he would
get his free agency um
and they certainly wouldn't let him sit
there and back up jordan love
you know so um it's
if they really believe in jordan love
and really feel he's the next guy and
are
so dedicated to getting him the time
prior to needing to figure out if a
fifth year option has to get picked up
then rogers is gone and everybody in
green bay should enjoy their final
season with him
by the way rich if you are interested in
what peter king had to say earlier on
the rich eisen show you can go to
peacock and it is streaming
and you can check out that interview
that was in the first time go to the
youtube feed as well i'll go to the
youtube
i'm just saying there are ways that we
can give you that information what did
you think about his getup more
importantly what about the man bun what
about the kevin shirt the flip-flops or
the blade runner glasses
is that what it was i had i have not
seen the way you arrived oh god we gotta
get this too rich oh i mean are you a
computer like go to app packers right
now and check it out
somebody send this guy a picture i mean
flip-flops shorts
a uh nba jam style
t-shirt of kevin from the office with
the big bowl of chili
uh he's wearing doc brown's glasses from
back to the future too
man bun big time nice total david
beckham man bunning it yeah
uh as as um you know i said on
on this show and people can uh if i'm
not mistaken go to peacock
and the youtube stream to see it um when
he was saying he was
at peace and with everything and he's
saving bryson to chambers bacon from
you know the fairway or the green and
living the life that he has
i need to see that guy on the field this
fall
and i'm that's the professional of it
too is that i'm uh it's
i'm psyched this is huge i mean this is
a monster
opportunity for green bay to win every
game
is going to be just jam-packed with
drama
every game is going to be a mini season
in itself
and him you know he just looks
comfortable in his skin
he looks in shape he looks happy i mean
again
if the way he played golf and the way
that he's just gone about his business
is gonna be brought um successfully to
the field as a
an mvp defense this is gonna be
lit and they are one of the favorites to
win the nfc
there is no doubt about it and i don't
want to hear that
rogers could have won the same way in
denver
this year that is not the same thing as
staying put in green bay at
all him staying put in green bay is much
better for him than it would have been
for brady to stay in new england another
year
not even comparison you can't compare
denver's roster with tampa's roster the
one that brady walked into
so he is clearly comfortable in his own
skin
certainly where you've described the way
he's shown up today and
i cannot wait you know week one
new orleans man i mean like let's
go because they've got their own
quarterback situation and they're going
to now green bay stroll
in with everybody back and
roll it out like carpe diem
the whole season long and i would prompt
her to say
every concept of trotting the field goal
unit onto the field on fourth
and goal history it's all going to make
every aspect
of what rogers wants uh in terms of the
game being put on his
uh shoulders he's gonna get and i can't
wait
can't wait before we let you go we'll do
this fast because bob cost is coming up
on the other side of the break
with the big news with texas and
oklahoma you're a traditionalist rich
is there any part of you that is
concerned that michigan and ohio state
follow suit
follow suit where to go to the sec maybe
they'll create a
giant maybe everything
nobody's funny no seriously it's funny
we were talking about when the super
team
super league stuff was going down with
uh with the premier league
yeah um like what if cut like college
was built for the possibility of doing
that more than anything
and this is a step closer to that mm-hmm
you know and the big ten might be
looking at the the rest of the
remaining big 12 teams and saying you
know who could come
aboard here and who could come aboard if
the acc wants to jump some ship or
or what have you but we're another step
closer to it and oh my god hoskins just
texted me a photograph
that you're talking about about right
yeah yeah that happened oh my god
how would i look in those glasses not
good
wait the hair the glasses the hair's
nice judgment okay
can somebody photoshop that hair on oh
no i don't know if i want to see that no
no
no
no no no no we need rich photoshopped
into this look immediately
someone's got to get up smitch can we
get that let's go smidge let's go you're
at home let's go
hey rich all i have to say is you're
welcome okay and we'll keep the lights
on for you
have fun tokyo golding i'm gonna go play
golf with dt and chef
oh no wait is that a real thing that's
happening that's right me
dp and uh um the agent to the stars
agent orange himself reads
reed birdman oh my god oh wow
nice we're going fantastic we want
pictures live stream let's go
i think we should have uh you guys
should maybe tape something get it out
there your people want to see it
i'm just saying i'm out of all i'm
saying is i am i am
out of quarantine and i am taking it off
and this is something i'm very excited
about
nice hit him straight keep your head
down that's all i have to say
okay thank you very much bye-bye all
right rich
hey bud bye-bye there you go go have fun
playing golf
we'll just be here working that's all
and having mimosas
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here